[Music]
why are you fascinated
by dreaming because i can't believe
how much goes on
in my head when i i mean think about it
oh well all of our heads we fall asleep
and then you wake up
eight hours later and you don't remember
a thing you think oh i've been out of
action for that time
and what we know is that people are
going through a very predictable sleep
cycle there's all sorts of repair going
on to the brain and the body and then
about four or five times you go into
dream sleep
and you have these really weird dreams
and what's phenomenal is the research is
now showing us that these dreams are not
random
they are our minds working through our
anxieties and our worries and trying to
either knock the edge off of some of
those anxieties or problem solve and
what i find incredible is the number of
times i have woken up with a solution to
an experiment or an idea or a book
fully formed in my head
the first thing in the morning it's
happened to me again and again
and often with magic
actually so a friend of mine was doing a
television show here
and i wasn't really thinking about it uh
when i woke up in the morning boom i got
the entire item in my head even to damn
well the camera angles were and
everything and i just find that
incredible there's so much going on
offline as it were
i share this
interest i'm reading a book right now by
matt walker why we sleep and and for
those who are who are curious matt is a
very credible scientist he really
he really knows uh his neuroscience
fantastic book it goes more into the
the why and how and specifics of of
sleep
without a specific focus on dreaming but
i read a book when i was in college so
the very beginning undergrad i was
neuroscience for a period of time then
couldn't do the animal testing necessary
to work in the lab i wanted to be part
of which was with barry jacobs not
saying i oppose it completely i just
couldn't be hands-on with it at the time
and i read a book
named exploring the world of lucid
dreaming by stephen laberge which i
found to be very practical
and i don't know if you have any
thoughts on on lucid dreaming but it
does seem like you can experimentally
demonstrate that it exists just through
eye cueing and tracking
and you can improve it as a trainable
skill through journaling and
waking up at odd hours and doing various
things like i think mnemonic induced
lucid dreaming mild is one acronym
do you have any
any experience with her thoughts on
lucid dreaming
unfortunately no i mean i i did a book
called sleep school
night school sorry can be good if i
remembered the title of my own uh book
night school uh uh and a sleep
deprivation i haven't slept well for
years no um uh night school and so i
contacted uh stephen uh in that and he
was very gracious talking about lucid
dreaming i really wish i could do it it
sounds phenomenal i've only had one
lucid dream in my life which i woke up
and i was in a shopping mall i mean the
lucid dream and
i was only partially in control i mean
good lucid dreamers can can do whatever
they want i wasn't i was only partially
in control and i saw myself felt myself
going to a shop to buy a shirt
and that was it
i was
so annoyed with my brain because i could
have gone flying
i could have met a celebrity i've never
met i could have done all these amazing
things and instead my brilliantly
creative brain did a thing that i've
done many times in real life and
actually really isn't very interesting
that is my only experience with lucid
dreaming uh so so i i love dreaming uh
and and i found it very helpful i just
can't get the lucid uh thing i used to i
know it's terrible i used to
have night terrors
i used to suffer from night terrors a
lot which if people don't know
it's where you sit up you've got your
eyes open normally it's about 90 minutes
into the night and you scream out and
you think there's a demonic entity there
or something like that
and if you're sleeping next to somebody
else this wakes them up and they're
properly awake at that point you
yourself are still in deep sleep and so
you go straight back to sleep and
they're sitting up shaking going oh my
goodness what's the problem and they
can't get back to sleep at all so it's
worse for them that is for you
so yeah i did um had a lot of those for
a while and that's what got really
interesting to sleep i was thinking what
is going on in my little head that i
should i should see these demonic
entities
and well there's what's quite good about
having those is that
if you 90 minutes in you can't sleep and
you're a bit bored and you think well
you know let's make life a bit more
interesting from a partner you can sit
up and scream they wake up and then you
go back to sleep pretend you you had a
night terror
the upside of night terrors that's right
you're richard wiseman now that's that's
a great book title the upside tonight
terrorist is a great book title
so i
i do not frequently have nightmares but
i had a night terror a few nights ago
and i like woke up
screaming and scared the [ __ ] out of my
girlfriend who then
stiff armed me like a reverse
clothesline to try to keep me down
because she's afraid of me lashing out
and kicking her or punching her because
this happens every
six months or so yeah
it was a very very exciting evening i i
will say on the lucid dreaming side
in my senior year of high school i got
to the point where i could actually
i could actually
practice my sport at the time which was
uh
let's call it olympic style wrestling in
the us would be collegiate style
wrestling with a coach i'd never met at
the time it was john smith out of
oklahoma who's very very famous but i
was actually able to consistently
practice a skill
that transferred it seemed to have some
transference to the real world which i i
found almost unbelievable
i'm sorry that yeah you were you're
buying a shirt and
it would be a bummer if if i were to
only end up doing my taxes when i
induced lucidity but hold a second this
means that you can lucid dream
i can yeah but i i can lose a dream but
i will say that it is a very
perishable skill
if i do not
so i got to the point end of end of high
school and then transferring over to say
sophomore year in college
where i could
if i were journaling on a daily basis
immediately upon waking and
if you don't have any dream recall
trying to induce lucidity is pointless
largely so
those two seem to be closely correlated
or the development of one seems to be
closely correlated to the other
where i could induce lucidity
pretty consistently at least once a
night it becomes easier during longer
extended rem periods so let's just say
or very early morning which is why some
of the techniques have you wake up
around 4 am and then do a few things and
go back to bed but if i don't do the
journaling forget about it then it's
effectively non-existent
but if i end up so exhausted go ahead i
was going to say so
my non-creative mind sent me shirt
shopping i suspect you do far more
interesting things in your lucid dreams
other than practicing sport what what do
you do
oh you can fly around and have sex with
everybody those are kind of the two most
common
if people are developing this those are
where they usually self-indulge the most
in the beginning my experience was
in the very early stages it was very
similar to your shirt buying experience
right you would have like a glimpse of
lucidity doing something really mundane
and then you would wake up or you would
slip back into non-lucid sleep
so it does seem to accrue and there are
hopefully this doesn't make me sound
like a lunatic i think it's i mean it's
a very
for me at least through direct
experience like it's a very developable
skill
you can begin to extend your periods of
lucidity
using different techniques that seem to
have some reliable effect you know
so it's
it is a skill that is of great interest
to me but it takes so much work
on the
journaling training side that i that
it's it's just generally not a super
high priority okay also waking up at
like four in the morning to
to increase the frequency is not very
appealing given that i already have
insomnia what else have you learned
about sleep and
improving sleep and why did you stop
having night terrors if you stopped yeah
i did they are related a little bit to
anxiety and also related to being a
a warm room so actually if you sleep in
an ice box essentially
they pretty much go away
in terms of night terrors because you
mentioned your girlfriend they're so
worried about you lashing out
i think receive wisdom is not to touch
the person who's having the night terror
because they can interpret that as being
the demonic entity attacking them and
they will lash out
so keep your distance after just saying
the person's name gently
will will be so enough to bring them uh
kind of back i'll buy my girlfriend some
headgear and a mouthpiece she'll be fine
says that in terms of the sleep stuff
there's all sorts of things you can do
to improve your quality of sleep one of
the biggest ones that came out of night
school which i didn't know about was if
you've got kids who have recurrent
nightmares and this goes for adults as
well but particularly with kids
where it's the same nightmare
every night
during the day you get them to visualize
the nightmare but with a more positive
ending
so if they're being chased by a dragon
they visualize that and then you go
maybe it's a lonely dragon it's a
friendly dragon he just wants to be your
friend and actually that's got about a
90 hit rate within a very short period
of time for reducing those recurring
nightmares so there's all this kind of
simple stuff that's out there
i think all the stuff about this night
of two halves and and actually taking a
break in the middle is what we used to
do before electric light and and so on
the paradoxical if you're trying to fall
asleep the paradoxical approach which is
you try and keep yourself awake
so you're allowed to blink but otherwise
you have to keep your eyes open and you
have to actively not fall asleep it's
quite exhausting and you end up falling
asleep quicker again based on all sorts
of research so yeah night school was a
fun book to do
so then speaking to onset insomnia which
is something that i've suffered from for
decades and i go through periods of
not having it
be as a as acute an issue but the the
initial falling asleep portion for
people who don't understand the
terminology so there's the paradoxical
approach of
i
never tried the keeping my eyes open
part that that i haven't tried yeah so
you may try that yeah icebox i feel like
i've got that pretty well dialed yeah
use various devices to keep the bed cool
any other suggestions well there's
busying the mind if it's based on
anxiety so so just writing down those
anxieties and worries often clears it
before you you go to bed uh counting
backwards from 103's
phil's working memory basically uh and
it means those anxieties can't get in
engaging in
sort of
fantasy world so that when the dreams
and sleep comes along it's a little bit
more pleasant
and if you are laying there for more
than this is particularly waking up
during the night more than say 10
minutes waiting laying away from 10
minutes get out of bed and do something
non-stimulating but physical like one of
those kind of adult coloring in books
something like that do that for about 10
minutes go back to bed
if you're still laying there wait 10
minutes later get out and do it again
and after a couple of those
you start to fall asleep because what
happens is you what you're not doing is
associating the bed with the anxiety of
being awake otherwise that becomes a
stimulus response that other the bed is
a place where i'm anxious so moving
yourself out and occupying the mind and
going back again is another very
effective technique
you